i'm an astrobiologist and i study life
i'm interested in life here on earth and
i'm also interested in life out there
among the stars if we can find it
and
that's
really cool except the problem is we
don't really understand what life is
hey everybody you're going to love this
interview with
professor sarah
walker of the arizona state university
sarah's a friend that i met virtually
and she is anything but virtual she's an
incredible thinker in the real world in
the scientific communication space and
you're going to hear an exclusive
from sarah today into the impossible
exclusive that sarah's writing a book
about her travails and travels in the
world of the origins of life so look for
that coming later on in your life in her
life and she'll be back on the show she
assures me when that is out
uh today you're gonna learn a massive
amount of cool interesting stuff sarah's
one of my favorite favorite thinkers of
all time
[Music]
we talked about so much today
and
just a smidgen of the topics we're gonna
cover today involve the question of what
is life is that even a good question
what is time
is that a good question we even got into
things such as the origin of biological
systems as relating to the laws of
physics even cosmology
of course we had to touch upon
intelligent design i asked her some
tough questions about that subject as
well as her theory that she's developed
along with past guest lee cronin
so-called assembly theory you'll learn
about that what is that how can we
detect the impromature of life perhaps
here on earth perhaps in distant solar
systems perhaps if they come and visit
us through omuamua which we also
discussed avilobe and the efforts to
ascertain whether or not the
existence of techno signatures in the
form of objects that visit us should be
pursued further we talked about that
charles darwin his warm little pond
so much more her expertise is unbounded
and it's really a great way to continue
our mission into the impossible podcast
i'm so pleased to
reveal that we've been ranked number one
in all of natural sciences on itunes
and the apple podcast ecosystem number
nine in all of science it's just
incredible i never thought when i
started doing this just a couple of
years ago that it would lead to such
great success
and you my listeners viewers are all
part of this success equation i can't do
without you so please do share the
podcast with your friends share the
audio share the video please subscribe
to the video
uh as well because i put in some great
b-roll production my super producer
stuart volkow member of the pga not the
professional golfers uh association but
producers guild uh just adds in a magic
pixie dust to each and every video and
audio episode so that's dr brian keating
on youtube
and uh so today's episode is not one to
be missed i'll talk to you at the end
and give you some homework assignments
stay tuned and now enjoy this episode
with dr sarah walker of the arizona
state university
[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
all right everybody you are in for a
treat on today's episode
of the into the impossible podcast
with a phenomenal thinker a brainiac
a deep thinker a
astrobiologist
professor theoretical physicist
she does it all and she does it all
incredibly well i've been a huge fan of
hers for a long time and i'm just so
happy that professor sarah walker is
joining us on the podcast today uh sarah
how are you today all the way in arizona
i'm great how are you i'm doing well
uh so a quick intro professor sarah
walker is an astrobiologist and
theoretical physicist interested in the
origin of life and how to find life on
other worlds and she's the deputy
director of the beyond center for
fundamental concepts and science
associate director of the asu santa fe
institute center for biosocial complex
systems and
assistant professor
in the school of earth and space
exploration
and that is cc although i see some
conflicting things that your associate
professor some place i see your
assistant it doesn't really matter once
you get tenure and if you don't have
tenure uh you'll get it and we would you
know snatch you up in a second if we had
a chance here in san diego
she does a lot of outreach especially as
i'm at her clubhouse where i've met a
lot of people in virtual space but not
in real space
and she's prolific
engager of the public with scientific
concepts never dumbing things down
having multiple appearances at the world
science festival through the wormhole
npr science friday she does it all
and sarah so glad to have you here
great to be here i'm looking forward to
it yeah so we have a lot of um
interesting feedback from my audience
and we'll get to those later i always
take the host prerogative when my guests
are prolific authors and i ask them you
know explain the title and origin and
judgment of your cover so i had that
with paul davies and the interview we
put out recently judging books by their
covers you don't have a book yet
although i'm sure there'll be many
publishers dying uh to get your
scribblings and into the public's hand
in a book and if not let me be your
agent i will only charge 55
um
but i want to judge your paper the paper
that caught my attention uh so long ago
now almost four years ago origins of
life
a problem for physics i had the question
mark sarah what was the uh what is the
relevance of the origin of life to
physics i mean i could see for
biophysics but why is or a problem for
physics as a whole
yeah so
well i think
people confuse physics with the problems
that studied in the past rather than a
way of thinking about the world
so the the issue i see there is that
because we've come to kind of a deep
fundamental understanding about parts of
reality those are confused with physics
as a discipline rather than thinking
about this idea that physics is really
predicated on trying to look for deeper
abstract principles that are really
explanatory and have a large breadth of
explanation and so with the origins of
life i think that's really critically
important because
i find it hard to believe that life
doesn't have some deep fundamental
explanation
and in particular in the field of
astrobiology when we're talking about
whether there's other life out there in
the universe we really need universal
principles and therefore when you cast
it in that kind of framing it becomes a
problem for the mindset of a physicist
as far as how do i abstract this problem
to its essence and then how do i develop
a mathematical understanding that allows
me to predict features of examples of
the system that i've never encountered
um and i think that's actually really
the program for astrobiology is we don't
want to just
you know have aliens hit us in the head
or something we want to actually go out
in the universe and look for them and
predict where we should find them
and
the some of the research i've seen you
involved in particular in the paper
is kind of straddling the interface
between
information and complexity as well as uh
life proper you know life qual life
and i wonder you know i i don't want to
have this kind i don't want to ask you
this question even though people like
lee cronin told me to ask you this
question
um
i kind of get sick of uh of of me asking
it although i'd love to hear your
response if you like but it's the famous
question posed but not answered by
schrodinger what is life and i just find
it um a little bit you know it's like
wonder bread or something like that uh
you know it's it's yes it's technically
a question but is it a good question
maybe we can ask that instead of you
defining for the nth time as you've done
so skillfully um is it is it a proper
question or is it sort of like these why
questions you know why is there life you
know is a different question than what
is life so what do you make it with
well so first off i'm not i'm a
physicist that's not afraid of asking
why questions which is maybe why i ask a
traditionally non a non-traditional
question in physics um is that i don't
think that we should be scared of those
questions because i think by the
practice of asking a why question you
ask things differently than if you
didn't consider the why which means your
what questions are better informed
because they have some deeper principles
underlying them the what is life
question i think is ill-posed because it
makes some assumptions about
life as we understand it being a natural
kind or being actually a category in
nature and usually when at least if you
look at the history of physics it's not
like we were asking what is gravity
before we came up with the idea of
gravity we were asking other questions
like why do the planets have regular
emotion in the night sky or why does
this apple fall from the tree the way it
does or why does this you know ball roll
down this incline plane um and then we
came up with this kind of unifying
explanation that we call the laws of
motion and the laws of gravitation and i
think when we're approaching the life
question there's a lot of assumptions
that because we are life
we know what life is
and therefore we can just go in and
define it and what is life actually
makes sense as a question but i think as
you dig down deeper
into that question it starts to make
less sense to pose it that way so the
way that i like to think about the
question is what are the laws of physics
that would have features associated to
them
that explain the phenomena that we call
life
and that's a little bit of a mouthful
but i think what what the simple way of
saying it is there's something
underneath the phenomena we call life
that's probably a pretty deep
explanation um
and we should really be trying to derive
the properties of life not define them
right and i think maybe we could we can
even start there by um you know
recapitulating some of the notions of of
emergence which which you've spoken
about before but i think my audience
would would get a kick out of hearing it
from you i i always say you know life is
kind of like the supreme court's you
know 1950 something definition of of
pornography it's like we know when we
see it
and we but maybe we know it when we
don't or we know what it is when we
don't see it you know
more likely but but i wonder the
confluence of information and life as an
emergent phenomena and the concomitant
you know question of how does
consciousness emerge a lot of people
maybe conflate maybe erroneously i don't
know i'm not an expert like you are but
consciousness as being a prerequisite to
understand life in other words can you
have life without consciousness
certainly there wasn't maybe conscious
life uh before you know human beings
maybe or something like human beings um
and yet there was life so i can you talk
about this emergence and as morrison
said you know more is different and so
first of all what is emergence and why
is it why is it relevant potentially to
the origin of life
yeah so um
emergence is this idea that you can get
new properties at new scales of
organizations so like if you think about
you know reality being separated out in
scales which it's really not just that
we do that because we have to build
models of things um you know there's the
atomic scale and then atoms come
together to make molecules and then
maybe when you're talking about living
things you get cells and cells come
together to make multicellular organisms
or people come together to make
societies and when we're looking at each
of those different spatial scales
we see um
fundamentally new rules emerging and so
this is one of the reasons that anderson
said more is different it's not the same
at every scale we actually
see new properties and one of the things
that's probably the most mysterious
about emergence is it seems to be the
case that you can describe these scales
independently of having to refer back
down to the lower level scales so a lot
of so for example we can talk about
social dynamics without having to appeal
to say qcd or something right so we
don't need to have those theories of
like how the very basic component parts
work to understand something at a high
level like that um
and so
uh in sort of our traditional concepts
of science that seems kind of deeply
mysterious because people think or well
there seems to be some conflict um
as far as well
well are these genuinely new properties
or
is it the case that if we really had a
giant supercomputer and we could run say
the
interactions of all the elementary
particles in a social system we'd
actually really recover those high level
dynamics um and of course this gets into
more issues of
um like let's say maybe
something like metabolism you know like
i'm eating is there a particle
description of what it is for me to be
eating
um but then there's also the question is
there a particle description of what it
is for me to feel hungry um because
feeling hungry seems much more
subjective and intrinsic to the scale of
organization that i operate on so
there's some questions in biology that
seem
much more apparent that some kind of
emergent
description is actually necessary you
can't really reduce it to the particle
description
and it's interesting because in this
paper you talk about you know kind of
the emergence of life but the first
example that you give and you know in
the history of life's uh of life's
emerging properties of life is a colony
are these stromatolites which
um you know seem to be these mysterious
things in in australia um that uh or
collectives it's like we found some
isolated you know protozoa somewhere by
itself at least it's the earliest form
of life if i'm not mistaken and so it
seems yeah again even kind of cut it you
know breaking the egg even more the
chicken or the egg now it's like which
comes first the collective or the you
know individual in order to have a
definition of life and you know yeah
well i think i think again that's not
the right framing of the question
because the issue
is
that you're looking at it as two scales
but really the phenomena itself is a
multi-scale phenomena so people think
you know life emerged at like a cell
scale or something and cells you know
reproduced and then radiated out across
the planet but really um you know
there's other theories of the original
life that it was um you know like
biochemistry emerged from geochemical
cycles and then you start thinking about
it more in terms of ecosystem scale or
planetary scale and so i think this idea
this very it's a very reductionist idea
that we think life is about individuals
and it's not actually about individuals
at all it's about
information propagating along lineages
so a cell even if you think about a cell
as a structure as an individual a cell
has to constantly rebuild itself and
it's using the information imprinted in
the matter that it is to reconstruct
itself and then if you think about that
extended over time the structure that
you call life is actually the structure
that's extended out over time basically
the pattern that keeps reproducing
itself in in the material substrate
so a lot of the discussions i have with
colleagues and in particular this idea
comes from michael lockman at santa fe
institute is really to think about
the fundamental unit of life as a
lineage of information and we're all
just these kind of bundles of
intersecting information if you think
about evolution and i think this is
really related to the problems
associated to emergence so just to
because i think people have removed time
from consideration in the way we talk
about both physics because time is
supposed to be an emergent property
right time doesn't exist at the
fundamental scale it has to emerge based
on some properties of the second law or
you know there's all these areas of time
we talk about like the cosmological era
of time the second law the biological
arrow of timewise biology increasing and
they all tend to point in the same
direction and that's some big mystery in
current physics because there's no
fundamental concept of time
but in biology if you put time as being
uh more primary i think it actually
takes care of some of the issues of
emergence because when you're talking
about an object that has emergent
properties what you're really saying is
that object has more time in it
where time is actually a physical
attribute of the object and this is
something
that we're trying to do in assembly
theory because you think about like a
molecule as being all the ways of
assembling a molecule which is basically
looking at the structure across time
and so then you can stack you know that
whole hierarchy i did
of you know going from atoms to
molecules to cells to multicellular
things to societies as actually being
about how much time exists in an object
um and that brings in sort of the idea
that evolution sorry my light went out
um
actually is sort of fundamental to the
way that we talk about
uh what life is in the sense that time
actually has to be a part of the way you
construct theories that you actually
think things exist across time they're
not just an individual instance that
exists at that moment you're observing
it
yeah one of the questions i have about
assembly theory is that it could imply
if there's some you know end of of the
historical
deviations from a previous state
um you know let's say we get to the
ultimate uh evolution of society you
know we me we become university
professors and you know that's the
pinnacle of evolution yeah you know what
the proof is by the way that we have the
best job in the world sarah you know
what the proof of that is what what did
the man who achieved the highest heights
literally in history namely neil
armstrong walking on what did he do
after he retired from walking on the
moon he became a professor
so
let's stipulate that's the highest form
of evolution now if you then reach kind
of a stat a stasis and i can agree that
there's more complexity in a and then
darwin's a warm little pond which we'll
get to than there is in just water
molecules by themselves so assembly
theory would say there's more
information more stored memories right
um but you know eventually that comes to
some stasis but time doesn't cease so
how how can you reconcile those two
facts in other words and without knowing
what comes next after societies um you
know then then our collectives um that
time can then continue to progress in a
way that the biological psychological
cosmological all the different hours of
time would agree that yes time is
progressing if you reach some maximum
stasis
um
so i think part of the
this is a really interesting question so
one of the things i've been doing a lot
of thought experiments on is what does
the clock look like in assembly theory
but i i don't have like and me and i
have been debating about that but um
but i think um one of the key points is
if you think that there's an ordering of
events like i can't spontaneously
fluctuate out of the vacuum which
current theorem physics might say could
happen and i i think is actually a
logical impossibility so sometimes so
where where it gets interesting talking
about life is where
we have had a tendency in the past to
take theories of physics and draw them
to like their logical end state and then
accept that that's actually a real
possibility in our universe even though
it's ludicrous and then you come at it
looking at from the perspective of life
and you really see why it's ludicrous so
there's like this idea of boltzmann
brains or anything is possible to
spontaneously fluctuate into existence
and
part of the sort of argument that we
would make in assembly theory is no
that's not possible because you actually
need the specific sequence events to
make that object there had to be causal
structure
in place things that you might call
constructors or however whatever
language you want to use information in
the system to actually assemble that
specific object so you can't just get a
sarah for free you have to go through
the four billion years of evolution to
get to an object like me um so even if i
was static and i never changed in the
future you would still have that four
billion year time point but the but part
of the point is also
i i have to constantly reassemble myself
to exist so i'm not a static object i'm
i'm a a thing that is constantly
reconstructing myself you're constantly
reconstructing yourself right now so
even if you're just sitting there and
you're not doing anything your body is
metabolizing i'm like madonna i'm always
reinventing myself that's right
material girl
i'm also a material girl but roger
penrose's perspective that he doesn't
know what the material is and i think
that's probably pretty accurate
um so um
so i think um when you think about it
from that perspective i don't think that
the traditional notion that things can
be static in time actually even makes
sense um and so part of the the way
um you know we're playing with ideas is
is this causal structure if you want to
call it ordering in time is the
fundamental thing and that universe is
constantly assembling itself into the
next quote-unquote state although i
don't really i think states are kind of
a weird thing that we talk about in
physics for various reasons but the next
thing that exists um so so the universe
is constantly moving forward in time but
it exists in the current moment right so
it's that assembled moment so so there's
not really for things to persist right
like why does something exist across
time
um it actually becomes an active process
not a static one
so um i have a question from an audience
member named lee cronin and he says is
lee right about time now i i i don't
want to make this about lee lee gets
enough attention and he's no he's very
shy so you know it's it's hard yes no
question about lee he's very shy
um but i'm curious because we are
talking about time uh when we had a
conversation uh a week or two ago he and
i on kurt j mungle's channel theory of
everything which folks should check out
um you know he basically says that you
know time doesn't exist and uh you know
and and and because only through you
know only chemists have a have a true
proper understanding of entropy and time
is fundamentally a chemical process or
entropic process which relates to the
second one now given that there and i
said there's so many different
definitions of entropy and my my friend
and and maybe you know nicole younger
halpern as well
she has a great book coming out she'll
be addressed next month on the podcast
for quantum steampunk she talks about
the you know the advice that that von
neumann was was given i think to uh
sillard or somebody said when you don't
know how to define something just call
it entropy because nobody knows what
entropy is right
um i like the fact that so far we
haven't really preferred to entropy
or the second law but i think it is
appropriate to get into that and maybe
cut you know
my ratings really depend on on drama and
battles right
so lead through
physics
you and i have to speak on behalf of
physics okay so these chemists are doing
too much i call them chemists
is it is it a fundamental physical
concept um you know nicole talks about
the the elemental fundamental clock and
that you could have a two-state system
that's a clock and we use the atomic
clocks that are you know not strictly
two-state systems but um could such a
model in your theory have have a truly
said to be complex you know if you make
the simplest instantiation of an object
namely a two-state quantum clock
and that exhibits and it can do certain
things and has certain properties
associated
in what sense could we say that that
will continue to exhibit you know the
features of assembly theory that would
lead one in your rubric to account that
it has sufficient complexity to be
warranted amongst the pantheon of
different discussions of entropy et
cetera
yeah so so this is very much um
a work in progress i don't actually know
exactly what you're asking because i
feel like there were like 10 questions
in your video yes there were probably
more than that i guess imagine just a
simple two-state clock
you know is that is that sufficient to
account for time i know people say that
time is emerging
um you know but but we all know it again
like pornography we all know when we say
it uh so you know a simple clock how
does that fit in in the uh just uh
right so i i think this is one of the
places that maybe lee and i disagree but
i'm not entirely sure
that it's good yeah um because it is
like something that we're trying to
develop right so you know and part of
the reason that you want to work with
multiple people on developing a theory
is where you find congruence in your
ideas or when you convince another
person then you start to see that
there's some really interesting stuff
going on
um so i think i think one of the the so
the one thing i think that we do agree
on is that time is moving forward
whatever that is and that there's and
that is a generative mechanism for the
universe so time is actually the thing
that generates the universe um and then
i guess when i think about time in an
object i don't think about that linearly
though right so when we think about a
molecule existing as a you know a
certain amount of time or causation
exists in the molecule maybe causation
is a better word than time you can think
about all the ways of assembling the
molecule which means that that molecule
actually has a very complex structure in
time it's not one way that time like
that causation could have a sequence of
events to produce that molecule it's all
the ways um and so a simple example that
i like to do as a thought experiment is
just to think of a stack of legos so
imagine you know i was holding a stack
of ten legos and maybe like five were
yellow and five were blue and they were
arranged in a particular pattern
in order to understand the assembly
structure of that stack of legos i
actually have to take the legos apart
into the five blue and five yellow and
then build up the pathways so the
argument i would make is all of those
ways of assembling that object are
features of that object but to resolve
those features you actually have to
observe them across time because they're
not features that exist in any one
instant of time
and so and then if you want to see them
in a linear sequence of time you have to
do that over and over again but they're
all features of what could have happened
if you wanted to assemble that so so
time doesn't necessarily have a single
strand to it it's this very complicated
causal structure embedded in an object
but the universe as a whole is
constantly chugging forward in time so a
clock
um is kind of an interesting object
because you you want to ask well
how how much complex time is in a clock
or is the clock actually tracking the
the motion of the
uh the universe forward in time and i
think those are two different ways of
asking questions about the nature of
time in a clock very good so um
uh so i guess we'd say maybe lee is not
quite right or maybe it's not quite
complete so that will uh that'll
stimulate him it depends on what it's on
right so sometimes it's clearly wrong
um so i wonder you know if we can you
know hit some of the classics and walk
me through the current thinking of it as
a as a cosmologist i you know i'm not
nearly as in touch with the uh
underlying you know kind of state of
play of things although it's quite
fascinating to me and uh and yet i feel
like there hasn't been much progress in
some of the actual origin of life
in certain in certain sects there have
been um you know extremophiles and and
so forth but you know one of my proofs
that there has been some stagnation uh
in things like string theory is that you
know string theory is like the best
theory ever invented to describe string
theory you know it it has it has a lot
of uh has a lot of promise to describe
string theory but but can it describe
other things and i think that's what
gives something predictive about uh
value now if you go back to darwin's
paper i think it was the huxley it might
have been a letter to huxley or
something he said like you know if life
could begin in some warm little pond
with minerals salts and so forth and
this thing and that thing and proteins
and and whatever um then you know it
could evolve in other words that life
could sort of kick off in this warm
little pond which in my simple-minded
way of looking at it is not too
dissimilar from an experiment done by
the namesake of our chemistry department
harold urie and his student stanley
miller here at uc san diego
they did it in chicago but they were
later professors here
and that was this miller yuri experiment
and in my mind we haven't made much
progress uh since those you know initial
kinds of experiments which were at least
intellectually the error of the warm
little pond thought experiment of darwin
so can you take us to where where do
things stand you know in the kind of
replication of life not the
classification and we moved away from
that but the origin of life um you know
for ab initio uh and then uh perhaps uh
since you said nothing's off limits we
can talk about some of the criticisms
even from the intelligent design
community if you're willing to go there
yeah
go there i think i think they have some
legitimate arguments but i don't agree
with the
answer they provide to the argument yeah
um
yeah so actually so so i made a crack
that lee is sometimes wrong but we all
are but i think the thing that he's
really good about is um pushing the
boundaries and i think something he's
really right about is how much
intelligent design goes into current
original life experiments or
historically and what what he means by
that is when you're designing an
experiment you purify the reagents you
put them in a test tube you know exactly
what's in there you you crank a knob for
like if you want to you know put you
change the ph or you do you know add a
mineral but it's all very controlled and
very methodical um
and so basically the way i think about
it is you're putting agency into the
system you're constraining all the
boundary conditions so when you get a
complex molecule out like say you you do
produce
a molecule that is implicated in life
is it because that actually is a
spontaneous process or is it because you
as an agent that already evolved in the
universe control the boundary conditions
so tightly that you basically predispose
the system to generating that complex
structure um not that we actually make
complex things prebiotically because we
make really simple biomolecules um but
this this is sort of one of the problems
so if you buy if you buy sort of the set
of arguments that life is more about the
lineage and we're all just kind of these
packets of information um or these
features of assembly space that are
propagating and generating more
structure
um then anything you do is basically
becoming part of that living structure
because you're a cause for those kind of
things and so the real challenge of
original life experiments is to remove
our biological lineage and all the
agency that we've accumulated over four
billion years from the design of
experiments
and so this is something that is one of
the reasons that i really wanted to
start working with lee when we first
started talking is because he was the
only person that i felt recognized this
issue and the only person that was
really trying to design original life
experiments that could do this and one
of the ways he's doing that is through
this automation this digitization of
chemistry to basically build experiments
that are agnostic they're not designers
like we are
um and they don't have any
predisposition to what the chemistry of
life needs to look like and you
basically want to start from a messy
soup of things and try to evolve it
under all kinds of different um
simulated planetary conditions i i think
of it if we could scale this up it would
be like a planet simulator and and lee
and i are working on ideas about how
would you actually generate a experiment
at scale like you would do in particle
physics so
um my favorite sort of experiment to
compare this to is super kamiya kande um
which is one of my favorite experiments
in japan looking for proton decay so
proton decay has been predicted by
theories never observed in our universe
and every time we don't observe that
event we can bound the probability the
problem with the original life is it's a
chemical search problem chemical space
is huge it's exponentially huge
it's beyond exponentially huge the
combinatorial possibilities of molecules
you can get even for small number of
elements is just it's larger than you
can possibly fathom so the question is
how would you build a
experiment long large enough to simulate
planetary chemistry and explore enough
of the volume of the space that you
would expect a high likelihood for the
original life to pop out and that's the
kind of way we need to think um not as
designers of the original life but
asking how is this a process that
happens in the universe and how can we
bound the likelihood of it the longer we
don't observe it the lower probability
it is just like proton decay and we need
a theory to search it which is what
we're trying to do with assembly
theories so if you put those kind of
experiments together with something like
assembly theory then you have this kind
of
way of doing original life science like
the way that we explore the early
universe in cosmology or the way we
think about particle physics
so one of the things that the
characteristic of super case 8 uses you
know super you know pure
uh reagents the huge volume sometimes
they explode the photo multipliers and
then grad students have to go on a canoe
and we'll put a background footage of
super cameo canada here but i wonder you
know when you think about uh the you
know kind of this this challenge it's
kind of going the opposite way of miller
uri they literally did it with stuff you
got at the chemistry stock room in yuri
hall here at uc san diego you could do
it and uh and of course you know now we
know that it i mean it wasn't like
fraudulent data but but it was you know
it was far off from what we now know
about the origins uh and yet it's still
a few if you look at many many you know
kind of um uh proposals of at least in
secular books etc and even you know
popular popularizations it's always
pointed to as you know oh you got miller
uri and and you know some version of it
well it didn't exactly do it but but
we're confident some other but no i mean
it's not like we're saying oh well super
coming canada you know hasn't seen it
and therefore you know but we'll have
some version of super no all we can do
is run it longer as you say with a
larger fiducial volume and then with you
make up for time by having more
opportunities for decay and then the
properties of half-life then work in
your favor but this is kind of going the
opposite way miliuri uh which is to go
you know instead of looking at one
proton decay you're looking now you how
big an experiment would you need and and
and would it be imposing you know this
this purity upon it or would you even be
using physical chemicals at all or would
it be purely simulated
no it has to be physical right because
we don't know we don't understand what
physics governs original life it's not
like you can't simulate life in a
computer because you don't understand
the causal structure of what life is if
if we had the right physics we could
simulate life in a computer we can
simulate some projections of features of
life like evolutionary processes and
things in a computer but i think the
origin of life we can't simulate because
we don't know the principles
um but just on the point about miller
urey and comparing to the way the
particle physics community works say and
the way the original life community
works when you look at origin life
experiments globally it's always the
case that it's like a single lab you
know has their favorite molecule that's
implicated in life and they want to
understand if they can synthesize that
under quote unquote prebiotic conditions
where prebiotic conditions is again some
kind of pure reagents not necessarily a
mix of soup that would be present on the
early earth but some purified chemical
compounds that they mix together in
precise ratios and then they they
subject it to whatever kinds of
conditions that they want to study the
particular synthesis pathway and of
course that's an okay mentality for
doing science if you're an organic
chemist and you've been trained to to
synthesize a purified reagent but a
molecule is not life um and producing a
single molecule associated with life
under those kind of conditions is not
solving the original life and then
you'll get
one you know lab you know maybe making
amino acids over here under some kind of
condition that might be presumably
prebiotic and another lab over here
making a nuclear base and another lab
over here talking about the energy pumps
necessary in early membranes and there
is this sort of rampant assumption in
the fields that some people will will
really precisely articulate so nicolino
is one of these people that if we know
enough of those steps we'll be able to
just string them together and then we'll
be able to understand the mechanisms of
the origin of life but i think what that
view is missing is that each step is
precisely tailored to the particular
outcome that you want for that step
which means that we are putting um so
much agency into those experiments i i
like to equate it a little bit to like
verifying a number is prime if you want
to find the next prime that's a really
hard search algorithm because you don't
know what you're looking for but if you
already know it's prime it's pretty easy
to develop algorithms to verify it's
prime and so what prebiotic chemists are
doing right now is verifying primes by
looking for known molecules and doing it
under very controlled conditions and
they happen to be small primes because
they're not very complicated or hard to
get to and what we really want to do is
try to find what's large like what's the
largest prime and like how can we
predict that our priority it's like a
it's a much harder problem for origins
of life than as far as it's not even the
same like class of search problem that
we're doing right now as it should be
and
right and then again getting back to
this kind of controversy which lee said
in his interview with me although i've
heard him you know take multiple sides
of it it's like it's like stephen
hawking penrose says you know you always
want to make a bet with stephen hawking
because no matter what side you take
he'll capitulate and you'll always be
right because he always changes mind now
i've heard lee debate intelligent
designers and uh and have you know some
some very harsh upbringing you know in a
gentle gentlemanly scottish way that he
has
but i've also heard him you know say
that literally chemistry has an
intelligent design problem or
biochemistry has an intelligent design
problem you mentioned that you're not
afraid what what do you say to somebody
like past guest stephen c meyer um or
you know perhaps future guests of spoken
new james tour
uh you know who stipulate that yeah
there are these problems of you know
purity of very carefully controlled
initial conditions as you know from
physics training uh you know this is an
incredibly important and vital aspect of
characterizing any physical system
little on a biological system so you
know is is this uh you know destined to
to kind of always have this ambiguity
which drives human beings crazy not
being black or white um but you know is
there a point do if you had a steel man
or steel woman the uh the the points of
the id the intelligent designers the
steven c meyers what would you say and
then and then we could look at you know
countering it for example what what are
the biggest criticisms in this field of
origin of life
um i think see
well i mean i think there's a lot of
them but i guess the the main one is
just because we don't have a mechanistic
understanding doesn't mean that we need
to appeal to something outside of the
universe and i'm agnostic on sort of all
issues and i think what i i always try
to do is maintain an open mind that any
possible explanation is possible but i
see so many roots to actually having an
understanding of the origins of life
being something that we can understand
from physical principles within the
universe i think the problem is that
we're not asking the questions the right
way and even the way we ask the
questions is actually loaded the die for
intelligent design to be the explanation
because the way we talk about the
origins of life is wrong
and i i think we have we have too many
uh preconceptions about the problem and
the nature of what we are and the
assumptions that we understand what we
are
um that make it really hard to work in
this area and this is one of the reasons
that i mean i started in
when i was a phd student as a
cosmologist but one of the reasons i
really wanted to work on origins of life
is because the conceptual foundations
were so
poorly defined
and on some level i don't even care if
the way that i'm trying to pose the
question is right but what i do with the
problem and what i do with every problem
that i try to look at is look at how
people are talking about it and then
just try to turn it slightly and be like
there's another logically consistent
narrative with all the evidence we have
over here that nobody's actually looked
at yet so why don't we explore that one
and try to see where the possibility
space is for that one and that opens up
subsequent pathways and i just think
that people haven't really been poking
at the original life
things
from the right angles yet and and we've
seen that through the history of human
thought that we've had major
breakthroughs as soon as somebody came
up with some fresh idea to something so
i think any time that you want to
prematurely say a problem is unsolvable
is
really limiting
the potential of what humans can do in
the future um because i also this is
sort of a bias of how i think about
constructing theories um and maybe it's
a very david deutsche kind of view but i
really think that explanations are
pretty fundamental i mean they're
fundamental to the physics of what life
is like the my favorite kind of physics
is
uh the physics of theoretical physicists
talk about about going back to like the
pinnacle of like
you know that's like a really
egotistical way to study life but of
course it's the example of life i'm most
intimately familiar with and also like
cognitively when i do thought
experiments about life it's the one that
i have the most play room with but but
it's also like a carefully constructed
set of experiments because
mathematical physics has done so well
this idea of taking abstractions
mathematical objects and using them to
describe reality and then doing
incredible things with those
descriptions of reality like launching
satellites into space based on the laws
of gravitation or building experiments
like super county akande to look for the
decay of proton or discovering
gravitational waves which have been
passing through the earth as long as
life has been on this planet but we've
never made contact with that phenomenon
in the universe before
we actually knew to go look for it so i
think um i think the idea that we won't
have a theory that explains us is to me
incredibly limiting about the future
potential of our planet and where we're
going because if we do understand what
we are then we have control over that
phenomenon the same way that we have an
understanding of gravity and can control
motion and understand how to launch
rockets and things imagine what it would
be like if we understood what life was
right yeah i always say you know two
things one you know
these pro nature's under no obligation
to make things understandable to you on
the time skill of a phd thesis uh or a
tenure case uh but um but also i i say
to my you know i'm a practicing jew i
you know attend temples and and i do you
know practice in that sense
and i do read that the the torah every
day but um but on the other hand i tell
my religiously you know um much more
predisposed colleagues and friends you
know if you really believe in science or
sorry if you really believe in god you
should approach it through a scientific
lens because it might be the only clue
you know it might be that you know yang
mills theory or you know maxwell's
equations or whatever are are the only
hints that we can ever hope to get of
god talking in our language but moreover
if you tell your children
that you know life started purely
because of a miracle you know then i
think it limits their ability to at
least search for you know going back
even further to primary you know the
primary uh source material if you will
if you just say everything is done by
god and every every single thing is
controlled by some agent that you have
no access to because god is not
revealing himself to us uh and in our
modern age so i think that's incredibly
stunting of my religious friends and the
intelligent designers uh beyond you know
other other challenges that i've posed
to them but i think you had a oh go
ahead no you just want to pick something
really interesting your point because
one of the things that i've always found
at conflict that i don't understand how
to resolve is that intelligent design
seems to need to be a principle that
limits creativity in the universe like
it means that creativity is not a
physical thing
and the way i approach the problem even
when you said you know it's not it's not
necessarily the case that we should be
able to learn the laws of nature on a
university education time scale right
but we can so i use that as
observational evidence for the kind of
physics i want to understand and so then
you have to construct the problem well
why is it we can comprehend reality and
what is that as a physical process and i
think intelligent design misses the
ability to even ask that question
because they assume all of that just
came for free
um and so
it's trying to explain us but ultimately
it really doesn't explain us it it
sweeps any explanation for what we are
as special in the universe or different
in the universe under the rug and i
think the one thing that i think is
really deeply intriguing is as far as we
know there aren't any other physical
systems like our modern technosphere and
our participation in it as thinking
agents that are conscious right and an
ability to explain that it has got to be
pretty profound and really interesting
as far as how we understand ourselves
and our relationship to the cosmos but
also what else might be out there and so
um so i think your point about limiting
potentially limiting imagination is
really um
the part that
i would want to push back on i'm open to
alternative explanations yeah right i
see you as a very um
you know uh non-dogmatic very uh you
know ecumenical thinker in that you're
you're not gonna have an open mind so
open as carl sagan said your brains fall
out but other hand you're willing to
strengthen your position by taking an
opposing perspective which i find you
know quite quite the hallmark of the
best scientists on earth i think you had
a beautiful statement i forget where it
was originally but you said um you
talked about what's called the luca
the last universal common ancestor and
you said that it is akin to my field the
last scattering surface of the cosmic
microwave backer i thought that was one
of the coolest uh analogies i've ever
heard um explain to people what is luca
who who is luca and why is it uh so
important to study the oldest most
primitive things as we do with cmb
photons but why is it so important in in
the field that you've uh chosen to uh to
dedicate so much of your intellectual
effort to yeah so um so i think the
actual equation between luca and the cmb
came from nigel goldenfeld and i picked
it up from him because i think he's my
new colleague here yeah okay well that's
cool yeah so
you know condensed matter physicists
working on uh origins of life would come
up with those kind of analogies but um
but i love that i think it's
another hallmark for you young people i
have to say sorry to interrupt you sir
yeah very interesting but what sarah
just did is the hallmark of a true
scientist she gave proper attribution uh
and it's actually in judaism it's
considered a sin
it's called stealing thought like when i
ever hear somebody say oh i'm going to
steal that joke that's actually like a
pretty big sin because people are going
to attribute to you the credit that's
owed to other people in academia we
don't get away with that in our papers
but you could have easily gotten away
with that with me i wouldn't have known
but it's a sign of an expert scientist
to do what sarah did so for my young
audience i have a huge very rabid young
audience that's a lot of edu addresses
in my mailing list which you should all
subscribe to uh but uh i just want to
point that out
everybody keep going
is an abbreviation of last universal
common ancestor
so the first sort of problem with that
name is it's singular and most and
really we should be thinking about as a
population of cells on early earth and i
think one of the people that spoke about
this most eloquently was uh carl woes um
who uh discovered co-discovered the
third domain of life with george fox but
um he made a lot of arguments about
collective evolution in early life um
and this idea so so luca comes from
tracing phylogenetic trees so if you
look at all life on earth it has shared
biochemical component parts and if we
trace those histories back in time it
kind of converges in what we call the
last universal common ancestor um and i
guess my point of bringing up carl
rose's ideas is a lot of people think
that convergence means we're talking
about a single cell that lived on early
earth and everything radiated out of it
but what he really pushed was this idea
that luca might have been itself a
collective phenomena and this is
actually really how i think about it i
don't think that when some collective
feature just as if we like kind of
zoomed out and looked at life today
there would be common biochemical
component parts in every organism on
earth today
and
that's a phenomena that exists across
all known life
so the reason for equating it to the cmb
is that
because we're using genomic information
to reconstruct the last universal common
ancestor
it's kind of like the last surface of
information that we can look at and
actually and and so going past it
requires different tools um in the sense
that
the genomic tools are not adequate it's
like the photons you know give us
information from the cmb but not earlier
because they were scattering too much um
and so we have this kind of boundary if
we want to do these phylogenetic
reconstructions um so one of the things
i'm really interested in scientifically
and this is something that i spent a lot
of time working on with my students in
post-docs is trying to not look at
genomic reconstructions of life but look
at patterns in biochemistry like
statistical patterns so just like in
statistical mechanics developed in the
1800s we realized we could predict more
features of engines and things by
talking about temperature and pressure
and work these kind of macro scale
variables that coarse grain you know the
exact position and momentum of every
particle in a gas
um so far in biochemistry we've been
talking about the exact component parts
luca had to have dna luca had to have
well we don't know if i have dna but
like had to have ribosomes how to have
certain metabolism
and and people are trying to reconstruct
the specific component parts what we're
trying to do is say luca was a
statistical pattern in print on early
biochemistry
and let's reconstruct what that pattern
was and try to predict chemistries and
environments associated to that pattern
um and we do that by using scaling laws
and all kinds of other things but we
don't have to get into technical details
but then the idea is to try to
understand
when luff
when life became universal in the sense
that they're z-shared biochemical
component parts how do we understand the
patterns in those chemistries that we
can actually extrapolate further back
than luca just based on those patterns
which don't require genomic information
excellent
so now moving out from our uh vantage
point on earth i do want to talk to you
about more controversial topics like
aliens extraterrestrial intelligence
ufos but before we get there um i
understand that you know one of your um
you know i think it was your phd thesis
as a matter of fact involved uh what's
called homochirality and um and the
existence and i'm gonna probably get
this wrong but here's how i remember it
uh sarah and i'm looking you know for
free to the world's expert perhaps on
this uh but i always remember that um
that dna is right-handed as a
right-handed helix
um
i don't know actually
well because it has sugars that are
dextrose right the sugar connections
yeah the schnitzels are right-handed i
know that so like i was working at the
the level of like small molecule
symmetry breaking and the sugars are
right-handed and for amino acids is
left-handed amino acids
you know why i get confused on dna
why it was wrong in some textbook and i
never remember which orientation was
right because it it was like it wasn't
that one but now i have in my mind
anytime i hear which one it is it wasn't
that one
here's how i'm gonna teach you mnemonic
to remember it uh so dna uh is is
right-handed because life finds a way to
be right
oh i see okay that's the way i remember
it and there but but neutrinos are
left-handed an ordinary nude so that's
how i like so if somebody asks me this
neutrino right hand left i think all dna
is the opposite of a neutrino so
therefore dna is right-handed because
life finds the right way then nutrient
okay anyway
we'll probably have to edit this out
this is so boring but anyway um but
imagine you're looking out the space and
uh you know somebody tells you that or
they they just returned and they got
some you know ancient stromatolites uh
from pro from uh you know planet uh that
orbits around uh proxima centauri be or
whatever right um
you test it and it's um has equal
amounts you know it's it's heterochirol
i guess um do you say this guy's a fraud
you know this is nonsense
in other words
what is essential about the chirality uh
to the nature of life if anything
um
yeah so so there are some arguments that
only homochiral so one chirality
biopolymer so like when you take those
right-handed sugars you can link them
together
or amino acids only those would be
functional but it's actually really hard
to test that experimentally because
synthesizing
you know populations of
heterochiropolymers is hard because all
of our enzymes for synthesizing polymers
were derived from biology which has a
particular orientation to it as far as
so it's easy to make like a left-handed
um
protein
you know left-chain amino acids you can
maybe make a right-handed one because
you could imagine reversing everything
but doing something in between is
actually quite hard um so so that's so
there's kind of this implicit assumption
that functionality in life requires
homochirality um i am actually really
interested in a kind of different
feature of chirality more recently so
when i was a phd student i was working
on symmetry breaking so physicists love
symmetry breaking problems right so if
you have two things they're left-handed
right-handed and you only deserve the
left-handed one and otherwise equivalent
that's you know a symmetry breaking
problem and it turns out you can make
that problem kind of equivalent to like
an icing um phase transition like when
you have an up and down spin and so i
was working on models of how you get
that symmetry breaking prebiotically
but the thing that i've gotten more
interested in recently is actually
thinking about
chirality as a system level property so
if you think of like a biochemical
network like the small molecule
chemistry that biochemistry catalyzes
all of those molecules are either a
chiral or they have some chiral
orientation to them and one of these
things that we've been doing with this
kind of statistical mechanics of
biochemistry is looking at patterns in
life's use of chiral molecules versus
achiral molecules it turns out there's
very statistically regular rigorous
scaling laws like if you look at a
biochemical system and you look at the
size and creates its increase in size
the number of molecules that that
organism uses in its biochemistry
there's a scaling of how many of those
are chiral versus a chiral um and the
reason to me that's really interesting
is one it doesn't require appealing to
these large macromolecules to talk about
chirality is an interesting feature
because this is small molecule chemistry
so this is getting at the original life
scale that somehow chirality is actually
playing a role in the structure of
networks that become living
and if i want to get to the deeper
physics of that i think that's actually
deeply associated to what we're doing in
assembly theory and also thinking about
time like we were talking about
earlier
because if you think about a chiral
molecule and you have these
two-handednesses basically it's like a
symmetry breaking in time if you choose
one over the other because now you're
talking about not just that molecule but
all the assembly pathways for making
that molecule and all the ways that it
interacts with things in the future
so chirality i think is playing this
really interesting way about
funneling um
biological systems down specific kinds
of trajectories in assembly spaces or in
time
and that's some theory i'm trying to
work on that's motivated right now we're
working we have these patterns in
biochemistry that we've elucidated and
we're writing a paper on that now but i
in the long term i'd really like to
think about
a more fundamental theory for chirality
sort of like how chirality was brought
into like qft and all these other things
at some point like you know chirality
always comes up as interesting in
physics and i think about it more like a
physicist because i'm more interested in
like
in in those kind of questions and i
don't think we've gotten to the point
where we can ask those yet but i can see
hints of where there's really really
interesting physics happening with
chirality
right yeah exactly um
so uh and i think yeah that maybe
connects back to where we were um in the
very beginning but in at least in the in
the context of of cosmic analogies what
we want to do is look out
and uh see gravity see the forces of
nature when they were you know what's
called a linear regime and i'm you know
my my simple-minded way of thinking
about it is like what's the analog of
the biological linear regime you know
about which we could do perturbation but
maybe that's not the right way to think
about it yeah that's interesting i i
like that i will i will dwell on it okay
don't steal it without it i want to
steal it
i'll cut i'll catch you right-handed
sarah um so you spoke in this paper very
passionately also the original life
problem for physics um about the james
webb space telescope which recently not
only launched but made it to the l2
orbit and also assembled itself like uh
origami or some living you know uh
structure um you talk about that in the
paper and what we could see and and and
so forth uh with with planets and um you
know maybe going in front of these stars
and i wonder you know uh could we really
see you know evidence you you're
probably familiar of this um of this
discovery this announcement you know
touted so highly uh recently by
sarah guest on the podcast sarah seeger
and other colleagues jane greaves and
others the phosphine on venus
you know
i don't know how pertinent that is to
your particular research but at least
the james webb space telescope prospects
for detecting life on other skies
you link that in sort of a bayesian
framework i wonder could you talk about
what excites you about the web telescope
and and and what do you think we're
likely to learn and and how much could
we really shrink the bayesian confidence
intervals by discovery from web alone
um yeah these are great questions so i i
have thought a lot about exoplanet uh
biosignature science and in particular
using bayesian approaches where and part
of the the whole set of arguments there
is if you're assessing the significance
of a biosignature um so biosignatures
are you know things that we can
associate to life but they tend to be
for exoplanets really simple molecules
like phosphine is an example on venus
but phosphine was developed as a
biosignature for exoplanets
because they're remotely detectable so
other examples are things like oxygen
and methane
and this becomes very problematic as it
did in the case of venus because there's
a lot of possibilities of false
positives we can't exhaustively
um
get rid of all the possible abiotic
explanations for those kind of
biosignatures so so this kind of
bothers me on a few levels
one of them is that i really am
interested in trying to encourage the
astrobiology community to move more
toward having motivating theory we're
not looking for a biosignature we're
looking for life and if you can't come
back can connect that signature of life
to a fundamental understanding of what
life is and you're not learning
something new about life by testing some
hypothesis about what life is on an
alien world and getting you know some
feedback about that phenomena that
you're looking at i don't think that
it's quite the kind of science
astrobiology should be doing yet um so i
think i think the way we're doing
biosignature science right now is by
analogy to um life on earth so we're
taking molecules that metabolism
produced on earth and looking for those
in exoplanets and we don't know the
mechanisms of how they could be produced
abiotically or biologically on those
planets and it's a little analogy i like
to make is like we don't take geological
maps from mars and expect them to are
you know to apply to earth or vice versa
right so we don't take you know the
grand canyon and expect it to explain
the morphology of of valles mariner
however how is that pronounced
marinara and i'm like
i suppose right
right so so but there's this implicit
assumption we could take the chemical
map from earth for biochemistry and
apply it to a different planet and i
think that's really um
a mistake but if you want to do that
there are rigorous ways of thinking
about it and you can ask well what is
the likelihood of an abiotic mechanism
generating that versus a biological
mechanism and the problem is that we
don't and then you could kind of plug
those likelihoods into a bayesian
framework and if you had a prior
you know model for the original life on
that planet you could actually you know
get some probability of assigning that
as a biosignature and so it gives kind
of a framework for asking
questions about you know am i really
detecting life or not that's
quantitative and statistically rigorous
the challenge we have is we don't know
what the abiotic
probabilities are or the biological ones
or the prior for most biosignatures
so i think james webb will help a lot
because it's going to give us a lot more
of a baseline of what planets are like
beyond our solar system and give more
detailed um
uh
detailed observations but i think the
kind of thing that i'm more excited
about is like um
uh you know there's this whole proposal
for levoir habex and they're doing these
more statistical types of surveys of
planets and i think that's really what
we need to do we need to have a better
baseline of what exoplanet properties
are
and we need to build better theories and
here's one of the reasons i do this
for predicting um non-ambiguous
biosignatures because if you look at
like bayes equation for
uh detecting life and you have like some
probability that the signature you're
looking at is actually attributable to
life there's a couple terms that matter
one is is it possible to be produced
abiotically if it is you have a false
positive scenario
and then you need a really strong
mechanism for the original like you need
a really really big prior you really
have to be really confident that it's
actually produced by life or you have to
have a really strong biosignature that's
not subject to false positives and so
that's the reason that i think assembly
theory is very promising because if you
have a high assembly object there you
know the structure of that is such that
we don't expect there to be false
positives
and so if you don't know the prior for
the original life and you want to go
survey the universe for life without
knowing that prior then you have to have
some kind of signature for life that has
that structure it doesn't have to be
assembly but right now i think that's
the only candidate we have
and is assembly you know going to
potentially be the drake equation of
biochemistry and alien you know biologic
chemistry
the drake equation is a way of
organizing ignorance right so the drake
equation is supposed to be filled in by
other science right and so a lot of
people still want to use it to make
estimates because we have a lot to uh
you know that was proposed in what 1963
by frank drake so if you think about um
you know how many discoveries we've made
since then we know the likelihood of
planet formation we kind of have some
bounds on the likelihood of earth-like
planets but that probability for the
original life term is completely
unconstrained
because we don't know the mechanism for
the original life right um so
uh i think what assembly
will give us is if we could go say if
you could go and survey a bunch of
planets and say did the original life
happen on this planet then you could
bound that f sub l right um and and
that's the way astrobiologists should be
thinking about it i think is
how do we actually infer the likelihood
of life from the data sets we're given
not having an aha moment where we're
going to immediately see some signatures
and it's going to just be like like
that's how science works yeah i often
point that out you know just riffing on
what you just said you know science is
not about like getting the answer and
then just submitting the answer you know
there's uh there's uh you know two
thousand planets in our in our you know
galactic spiral arm no i wanna know the
uncertainty on it and the problem with
the drake equation is that it's always
presented as here's the number and
there's never error analysis associated
with it so is that true of assembly
theory too is it just going to give you
a number you know probability or is it
going to give you some bounded error
bars and some bayesian interval
confidence interval oh no so yeah so one
of the things with the whole like
bayesian approach to biosignature
science is it allows you to invent new
kinds of bio signatures that fit in that
formalism and assembly theory is
structured that way because it's a
it's a theory that naturally
accommodates probabilistic assessment
so the whole idea is like with this so
empirically um you know lee's lab
identified that if you have more than 15
steps to produce a molecule in the
shortest assembly pathway then it's
exponentially unlikely to be produced
and if we see it then it becomes a
signature of life and that was like
empirically validated against
experiments and right now we have some
theory that corroborates why there's a
threshold value um that we're working on
now in the current paper
so the theory would predict there should
be a crossover point where you where you
wouldn't expect this um
by um a non-biological process basically
or a process that didn't undergo
selection um or didn't have any kind of
information or causation in the system
um so so if you you buy that sort of
argument basically what it's saying is
above 15
it's exponentially unlikely to ever
observe those molecules and there's a
two-part argument to it it's not just
it's 15 steps but when you see a
molecule and you observe it with your
instrument like a mass spec you have to
have multiple copies of it um and so you
might argue
say based on the boltzmann brain
argument and people do this they're like
well geochemistry can make anything and
i'm always like well geochemistry can't
make a cell phone where you draw the
line
but
i mean the line has to be somewhere
otherwise you're arguing for intelligent
design and i think people really don't
understand this it's either biological
agents or the designers or the universe
has some kind of intrinsic uh design
based laws
um and since i i i'm looking for
the the situation where we can explain
that physics internal to the universe
and don't have to appeal external then
it's not that you can get certain
objects for free it's that there have
been specific pathways constructed to
make those objects
um and so
with that argument means that when you
find one cell phone you don't find just
one cell phone you find that everybody
on the planet has a cell phone it's not
an isolated occurrence like people you
know you never expect a single person to
appear in the universe you would expect
a population of people um you would
never expect a single copy of a molecule
to appear in the universe it needs to be
in a population of molecules if it's
part of a process that's reliable to
produce that molecule and it's not a
statistical fluke and it's actually part
of a metabolically product now there
might be some smearing of the
distribution not all people are
identical not all molecules needed by
identical but they need to be somewhere
related in the assembly space um and we
have ways of accounting for that
well then um
then the idea is
if you find these molecules that are
past that threshold then you've found
evidence that there had to be some kind
of causal mechanisms producing them or
some kind of selection or what or
information or what all these words
emergence complexity you know whatever
word you want to associate to life but
it's evidence of life so it's agnostic
as to you know what what um
type of chemistry could produce it you
know could you have silicon based life
could you have
you know in other words are you are
other biases or you know confirmation
errors that might be imposed
there are
so one of the things that i i think is
of interest is trying to understand
the assembly structure of different
kinds of physical systems so it might be
that silicon doesn't you would never
expect to see high assembly things in
silicon just because of the way the
assembly looks in silicon chemistry
but my anticipation is that probably yes
you would still expect it now one thing
is that depending on the structure of
the system that you're looking at you
might expect the threshold value to be
different so we can predict features
based on the causal structure of the
assembly space of where that transition
should be
where it's necessary to have some kind
of informational system produce that
object but we expect that transition to
happen in any kind of assembly space
that transition happens just because
we're talking about a system that is
combinatorially huge so the number of
ways of making that object um grows
exponentially with the the the size of
the object um and so there's this kind
of transition where the path the number
of pathways for assembling it is too
large for you to expect it to form by
chance um and that's a fundamental
feature of any combinatorial system
where you impose a causal structure on
it um
so so so that's sort of the underlying
premise of assembly theory is basically
saying when you see things past that
boundary for that particular uh assembly
that particular kind of causal structure
combinatorial space that's evidence of
life or that's evidence of the physics
underlying life
i see
um and then one one thing that we talked
about
maybe on clubhouse you know longer time
ago uh
you know it's kind of this this
notion that i again was brought up with
lee and and and iron curt which was you
know that
are the properties of life encoded in
the big bang in some sense and before i
get to that i want to ask you know can
assembly theory discard like irrelevant
or low value information for example
people talk about water you know oh we
found water you know uh and and on mars
and there's evidence of i'm like of
course you know hydrogen is the most
common element oxygen is like the fourth
most common of course you're going to
find a lot of water um you know so in
other words is that you know finding
water is that is that this positive is
that in any way or is it can you just
exclude it because it's so abundant it's
it's almost like a nuisance parameter
yeah so um
so
assembly theory is falsifiable like if
you found a high assembly thing and you
couldn't associate to life you can
falsify the theory but i think one of
the things is it's trying to get rid of
all those kind of details
and the water argument is more of one of
habitability than life right so so there
has been
traditionally also in astrobiology this
confusion between talking about the
components of life as life right so
that's like you know these single
molecules become represent like oxygen
oxygen is not life oxygen could be a
signature of life with a whole set of
other assumptions associated with it um
and uh dna is not life either dna is
evidence of life because it's high
assembly object it requires a lot of
design and evolution oxygen is kind of
so you can see where those fall on in
sort of an assembly structure but things
like water are preconditions for life
right assumed preconditions based on
what we know of life on earth so life on
earth requires water therefore we go
look for environments with water because
we assume that life couldn't exist in
the environments that don't have water
so it's kind of like we're trying to
screen out the search space
and focus it in but
but assembly theory is kind of agnostic
to that because it just says you need to
have an environment that life could
emerge whatever environment that is and
and that um
and life could build complex things and
then you would look for those complex
things now it might be that some
environments life doesn't build complex
things and their glowy assemblies are
sold um but there are also ways that we
can detect features of selection or
light of information processing below
that that we're still developing
so interesting um and then what did he
make of this uh this conjecture by uh
by avi loeb that you know the universe
was once uh you know at age you know at
the ra at a redshift of 100 the universe
was approximately room temperature
meaning that you could have a liquid
water um and actually over a wide
variety of time scales and so liquid
water was was
perhaps abundant in the you know just
ambient universe uh does this does that
play a role you know cosmic connect i'm
trying to push back the last what i want
to do is push the last common luca back
to the last scattering surface so i want
to get it closer and um
i just don't see the utility i mean what
what does that give you it just it gives
you an interesting thing to say i think
it's curious i think there could be
something there but
do i follow the chain of logic to say oh
i have observational signatures of life
living in the period of the universe and
i haven't seen anybody actually go that
far so i mean i can spend all day making
wild conjectures about
what life what could be life and where
it could be in the universe i have a
million ideas a day about it but i think
the thing is like if you really want to
discover aliens
and some of us really do i mean a lot of
us do abby included right like then we
have to sit down and we have to really
think rigorously about the problem and
develop theories that we can test and
things that we can do in the lab
observations we can make with telescopes
and theory that we can build and those
three things have to work together just
like they do in in physics but
astrobiology hasn't transitioned because
it's not a mature science yet it's a
really new field and it's bringing
together a lot of areas of science that
haven't worked together before we don't
know how to ask the question of life we
we make a lot of assumptions that we
know what we are
and um
and you know the way we all know it when
i see it is so pervasive i'm glad that
you brought that up earlier it's funny
but it's true because people assume
we're life we know it when we see it but
yeah so so i think i think
yes it's fun
yeah yeah so i think it's fun to talk
about the water in the early universe
and and could it have been the case that
life could have emerged really early in
the universe but i don't think it's
helpful to any discussion about actually
solving any of the problems that we're
dealing with okay well remaining on the
avilo uh bandwagon for a second uh so
he's had uh you know kind of a lot of um
maybe dissonant
conflicts with the astro astronomy
community but primarily you know what
he's advocating for is that we spend all
this money on on you know kind of
wasteful science string theory and and
you know bigger and bigger accelerators
and so forth but we really should be
studying is not even spending it on seti
which is like information um looking for
techno signatures in the radio wave or
light waves uh and as i mentioned before
they really pivoted from you know the
pure core mission that they had from
drake's time until you know in morrison
until today which is looking for
extremophiles and and all sorts of other
you know life on earth at redshift zero
um but what do you make of his claims is
sort of you know we should be looking
for physical you know techno signatures
like like this little chunk of a muammua
that i captured uh not too long ago
going across my uh but but tell me what
are your thoughts about this
nft
that's right i have been actually i did
get approached by somebody who does is
making nft meteorites and i'm just like
all right well don't look down don't
look good um well tell me what do you
think about a muammar i don't think i've
asked you this before
yeah so i think some of the features of
being open-minded and
realizing that aliens could be right in
front of us and and it might just pass
us by are really um good about
the way that abby is approaching some of
these questions um but i think in the
case of i'm i'm
i can never pronounce this one either
like you could run the whole bayesian
thing we just talked about and there are
really good models actually including
developed by one of my colleagues here
uh steve dasha asu that explain
amumua in terms of completely natural
um explanation including some of the
anomalies that um abby talked about in
his book like they've been basically
like all of these sort of features um so
i i think there's a lot of evidence that
you know suggests it could have a
natural origin and it's not an anomaly
um now the real issue i think is not
in the debate around that but the whole
issue of our anomalies adequate
to assign alien as the explanation
and we do this everywhere we do it in
ufo science we can't explain it as
aliens
we can't explain it it's aliens
biosignature science phosphine on venus
we can't explain it abiotically it's
aliens saucers yeah yeah so i think i
think culturally culturally and this is
ubiquitous because scientists members of
the public everyone aliens right now are
the other they're the explanation for
things we can't explain and i just don't
feel like that's adequate i don't i
think if we don't understand what
something is we should say it's an
anomaly if we have a mechanism and we
can explain it and that mechanism
happens to be associated to the
phenomena we call life and we can say
this is an example of life that's not us
then we use the alien hypothesis right
it's not science if i'm just saying
everything that i don't understand is
alien
what about my your former colleague and
uh you know paul davies and current
colleague also uh you know talked about
the shadow biosphere
right yeah i could knock on the door
yeah um the shadow biosphere and these
lurkers and our solar system and as he
wrote about i pointed out to him
you know we've done multiple interviews
one was on the eerie silence on the on
the 10th anniversary of its publication
which was itself on the 50th anniversary
of the seti program kicking off yeah the
silence has only grown more deafening in
that realm so his his theory of you know
shadow biospheres and so forth and what
do you make of that isn't that just kind
of
saucers by another by another name
um other by another name um well i think
the shadow biosphere was intended to be
a hypothesis to be tested right so the
idea was
um if
life is not a singular event in the
universe and it's common um and it's
common on earth-like planets the most
earth-like planet is earth and we know
that worldwide happened once here so
maybe it happened twice and we just
haven't actually recognized that yet
um and actually there's a lot of
historical precedent for this because we
have discovered alien life on earth that
we didn't know about it just happened
that we found out later it was related
to us so for example you know for most
of human history we didn't know microbes
existed we had to develop the technology
of microscopes to actually literally see
that there were these organisms
basically living in our bread and you
know on the table top and pretty much
everywhere around us but that was a
completely hidden quote-unquote shadow
biosphere for most of human history and
so the argument is um if it's not dna
based life and we're only combing the
seas like in craig venter's things you
know going through the ocean combing up
life and and detecting it based on dna
sequences what are we missing
um and so so paul's very adamant that
you know it's cheaper to look for life
on earth than it is to go look for life
on mars so why don't we just have a
concerted effort to look for an alien
example of life on earth that isn't
actually alien to earth it's just alien
to us because it's also originating on
earth um my personal perspective on it
is that's a well posed scientific
question and we should be doing that i
think from the philosophical side of how
i approach the science and what's
consistent with the kind of theories i
do and the kind of work that my group
has been doing
uh thinking about the global
organization of biochemistry and
patterns in biochemistry i don't think
that you can have more than one example
of life per planet um and um because i
think life becomes a globally integrated
system pretty quickly and it's actually
like a planetary scale process and you
can think about that even with modern
technology and the global internet and
how we're all increasingly connected i
just i don't see you think about life as
as information propagating and the kind
of structure of it i don't see the
possibility of having more than one life
on the planet but from the perspective
of is it a well-posed scientific
question yes it absolutely is and it's
and i and just to i didn't mean to imply
that like the the whole set of
biosignatures from ufos to phosphine are
not well posed i just don't want like
you need to have a conjecture there like
about why is this life and actual like a
theoretical support um other way like i
i just i don't understand the mentality
and maybe i'm just missing something but
i i feel like there's more rigorous ways
of approaching the problem that people
have just shied away from historically
because the life problem is so hard yeah
absolutely
um so if you'll indulge me for another
10 minutes maybe we have some audience
questions is that going to work
okay good
so first question um comes from
dylan graham hussman on my youtube
channel comment community section it's
dr brian keating on youtube uh dylan
asked given the non-ergotic nature of
life and the vastness of genetic search
space
do you think mutation and thus evolution
is purely random or do you think there's
a set of principles that constrain the
space of mutations to places more likely
to produce adaptive change
so is this kind of uh evolution being
pre-patterned for certain adaptions yeah
is it purely random or is it or is it
you know traceable to some sort of you
know set of principles maybe design
um yeah
i mean i
i don't know where i stand on that like
so some days i think that there's some
intrinsic randomness in the universe and
other days i think it's totally
deterministic
um so
so i'm personally deeply intrigued by
this i think that there definitely is
some contingency in
um you know what mutations happen and
which and the ways they're adaptive and
certainly there's been experiments done
to show certain features of that kind of
contingency so
it doesn't seem that they're all totally
random like certain parts of the genome
are more biased toward mutation than
others is a simple example um and then
you can ask questions about why and
there's tons of people that are way more
qualified to talk about those kind of
you know specific genomic questions than
i i am i think i think the question of
whether
um
whether the universe requires some kind
of
underlying stochasticity or randomness
in order for life to exist is a really
deeply intriguing one
um
yeah
uh next question comes from a
audience member named rust in peace
which was coincidentally the name for my
uh first daughter no no i'm just kidding
um and he or she asked could it be uh
that a living organism doesn't require a
cell wall or you know some kind of
container
um
i think there's certainly a so i don't i
don't think life has boundaries in the
traditional sense
um i do think that you need bounded uh
bounded structures but i don't think
like you know the container is the thing
that's important so as i mentioned
before like a cell
reconstructs itself and is part of a
lineage and the lineage is really what
we need to think about with life so the
boundary plays a role in terms of saying
this is a packet of information that's
reproducing itself in a in a particular
structure but then you know organisms
can exchange genes with each other or
even now like we're exchanging knowledge
so the boundaries are not as important
as sort of the flow of information in
the system so i think it's kind of a
secondary feature and in fact there are
some things that you know individuality
the idea of like bounded individuals
might have emerged late in the origin of
life and that you might have just had
much more collective or like system
level properties early on and i i i
resonate with those kind of ideas i
think they're they're really intriguing
so maybe you know really primitive life
is not bounded but maybe once you get
into this kind of darwinian and
well-defined information a lineage as it
becomes bounded
uh next question from vorador what is
your opinion regarding the chances to
find life on let's say
he or she asks about europa specifically
but what about other places in our solar
system um i think it's possible for for
life to be a lot of places in our solar
system and that we just really haven't
figured out how to identify it yeah i
think your rope is hard
mission wise because you have to drill
through the ice shell
and so getting a sample is really
challenging but i so um for that reason
i'm much more on team enceladus so to
say like i'm very enthusiastic about
sending missions to enceladus because
enceladus is very similar to europa
another icy moon um you know has a
liquid ocean under its shell but it
actually has active jets of um
material being spewed into space you can
imagine flying a
you know a
robot through the plume and taking
samples um so you don't have to worry
about the drilling problem and from a
habitability perspective of like you
know are the ingredients for life
present on these icy moons i think
enceladus is just as strong a candidate
as europa so that just becomes an
accessibility issue great
uh another frequent guest on my channel
the means of destruction or audience
member it's another good name yeah
these are all great band names i know
there's another one chimbraso we'll get
to that uh he asked our stars alive i'm
going to change that to
you know what's the minimum you know
kind of astrophysical entity that you
could say
uh is alive or a features life uh could
you have a dark cloud like arthur c
clarke or uh you know what what's the
minimum
uh common ancestry plan
is
astrophysical uh prerequisite
yeah so so this is not the way i would
ask that question um so i'm gonna answer
yeah so because it's kind of like the
what is life question and then what were
other examples of life this is what we
would canonically think and i just don't
think that's the right way of framing it
what i i would think is clearly we exist
in the universe as life which means that
the laws of physics are structured for
life to exist and i'm interested in
those laws that specifically explain
life which my claim is are not the laws
of physics as we know them now they're
different kind of law of physics and
they have very different the laws of
physics that explain life have very
different properties for example they're
not cast in this kind of initial state
fixed law of motion kind of framework
which we didn't talk about but like
that's an aside but anyway just imagine
you know there there is some structure
to the universe causal structure the
universe is a causal graph so to speak
an assembly space um then everything
has that property just like everything
um has the property of existing in space
and time in in gravity right like
there's a space time manifold that
defines the properties of the universe
and then some
physical systems like us are very high
assembly and you can think of them like
in the gravitational analogy as being
objects that have very strong
gravitational potential wells like
planetary systems galaxies or black
holes are good examples to study
gravitational physics things that are
good examples to study causal structure
in the universe or this kind of feature
of information being causal or whatever
you want to call it are living things um
now is that apparent and in other
examples like stars or other kinds of
systems we could study of course it
should be because it's a feature of our
universe um but the question is to what
degree
um and so i wouldn't really call things
alive unless they're very high assembly
objects like the kind that we talk about
in terms of molecular assembly theory
but assembly supposed to be general
applied anything um
and so i don't think stars have crossed
that threshold but i think that stars
have
uh you know like you can think about the
contingency in stellar generations and
the kind of elemental distributions they
have they do have a clear this
population of stars had to come before
this population of stars otherwise
there's no reason for this elemental
distribution so they have a causal
structure associated to them
right
okay next question
comes
from tim brazo he has a bunch of
questions one is about humans and aliens
interacting how would we communicate
with them you could ask answer that
question he also asked why does a grand
unified theory have to be beautiful i
guess my question to you would be you
know what what about these um you know
that your love of physics your love of
cosmology or your kind of og uh
historical uh legacy uh what interests
you most and what do you find most
interesting about um the searches that
are
kind of layered upon them as this
question of beauty and and propriety if
you will in the laws of nature we talked
about symmetry earlier uh what do you
make of that is that is that baggage is
that a shibboleth what's going on with
that
no um so so on the question of beauty i
think um
you know a lot of people think that's
problematic for physics and i think it
can because i think you know there are
obvious
areas where maybe we get romanticized by
certain ideas and then we lose track of
you know where where's the scientific
rigor
but i also think
um that our attraction to beauty and the
way we explain the world is probably a
signature also of the physics of what we
are and is not just like an ad hoc
feature added on to it um but i think um
i think it just depends on what your
aesthetic is
um and for me i think the aesthetic is
is it explanatory i don't i don't um
and how much does it explain
and i'm also deeply interested in and i
in theories that are empowering so i
think um and what i mean by that is
because i think theories actually are
causal and they matter to how the world
we live in locally on our planet works
because the theories become the reality
we live in
it is important to try to pick ones that
maximize kind of potential for humanity
so it's not like an aesthetic choice but
it's more of a
well it is an aesthetic choice but it's
an aesthetic choice informed by thinking
about theories as physical objects and
like what they do so um so i guess i
don't have any problem with people
choosing aesthetic choices but i think
that i guess my point is we need to be
very cognizant about why we're making
those choices how it's related to the
physics that we're developing
and where the biases are coming in
and so one thing i always try to do is
is try to understand what my own biases
are and my my biggest bias is i'm
trained as a theoretical physicist so i
tend to think like one and we have a lot
of baggage that we go with um and i'm
okay with that but it might not be the
right way of even asking the life
problem right it could be like you know
physics completely irrelevant but i
don't think that's true but but it's
entirely possible good so now move to
twitter to the twitter space where you
maybe have seen some of the questions
posed to you the first one uh we'll
choose from caitlyn mcshay
santa fe mcshea and by the way you
should all follow sarah at uh sarah
underscore amari i am follow caitlyn too
she's amazing
caitlyn you just got a shout out caitlyn
hope you're watching listening
yesterday what's your favorite
philosophical textbook
book
uh this is a hard one i think um
i should have looked at these ahead it
would
um
i think um i think it's always nice to
kind of know like the like earliest like
ideas of how people think so
i'm not a philosopher by training i took
one philosophy class and it happened to
be when i was at community college um
and i've always had an interest in
philosophy but it's kind of like one of
these things that now that i'm a
middle-aged physicist i'm starting to
read more philosophy because i need help
um but when i was a student um i think i
really like was i was so struck
by two things one was in my physics
class the fact that we could predict
magnetic monopoles and we we couldn't
know we could look for them sorry i
don't know where my lights went they're
not coming back oh there they are and
the other one was um
uh thomas aquinas's arguments for the
existence of god which i thought were so
clever
um and so i i really enjoyed reading
that i don't know really i think um i
think both of those together really gave
me some insight into the power of human
thought and how far we could push it and
since i
became a physicist that was always the
thing i was romanticized by is the fact
again it goes back to like why is
reality comprehensible and why are brain
structured to even reason about these
kind of problems and look how far we can
actually push that reasoning both in the
sort of abstract philosophical arguments
um that we might want to run through or
in the sense that we can predict futures
of the universe and actually go and look
and verify if they're true or not um and
i think those those two things are
are just really important features i
think so so i guess that's kind of a
half-assed answer but
an answer
i like it very much
uh next question
also coming from twitter there's about
50 from uh one person uh sandy bachaldi
uh but i'll just ask um
uh
one of it he says basically what does it
even mean that time can flow in any
other direction than before to after i.e
what we call forward
i don't know because i think time only
flows forward i don't know why most
people think they could go backward
so so i'm with you on that question
please someone explain to me why it
could go backwards yeah all right well
you could ask wow
i i i think sort of just like i i think
you know yeah never mind we'll just
leave it at that that's good
and then uh
bryant woah times asked what does fine
tuning of initial conditions have to do
with free will
okay um i think i might have made this
argument on twitter at one point um
which you should all follow because
she's hilarious prolific philosophical
brilliant on twitter
masterful
um so what uh what so
so there's this whole sort of conception
in current physics that in order to
explain the complexity now like you know
the fact that we're sitting here on this
podcast talking and you guys are
listening um
was a feature then like and like can be
traced back deterministically to like
the initial state of the universe so so
then this becomes a fine-tuning argument
because in order to explain all the
variation and all the structure we have
in the universe it had to be some minor
fluctuations in the initial condition of
the universe and the initial condition
had to be fairly ordered to explain why
disorder hasn't ranged so there's all
these kind of criteria on the initial
state of the universe um that are
imposed by the features that we observe
now um and if you trace that chain of
logic um basically it means that it sort
of every action
that you're doing now was already pre
imprinted in the initial state of the
universe so there's sort of a conflict
between current physics and free will at
a cosmological scale because it's not
really it goes back to the intelligent
design versus creativity discussion we
were having earlier
that these questions are actually deeply
buried in the logic of how we talk about
physics
and it goes back to this idea that sort
of the laws exist outside the universe
and and the only thing you need to
specify what happens in the universe is
basically the initial condition so once
you set that in motion everything is is
predetermined um
and i don't think that's the right
paradigm for talking about life mind
free will or any of the problems that
you know you hit up against when you're
talking about what happens in biology
versus what happens in physics and it's
not that physics as we know it is wrong
it's just that the kind of structure the
equations that we study in physics are
not
the right kind of structure of the
equations for those kind of problems
i got it
and then the last question before we
wrap up with closing arguments uh is
from stur devant
who asks how often are my cells created
in origins experiments and in nature
um how important is a lipid bilayer to
first life
uh it's interesting that a micelle is
used to protect plasmids in gmos as well
as mrna vaccines
uh is that essential do you know what
these micelles are can you define them
um i so a lot of people talking origins
of life about um forming vesicles so
like if you have fatty acids they
basically self-organize into your
spherical structures so you can have so
there's some hypotheses about cells
before life that you had you know these
micelles or vesicles forming and then
some molecules got in them and they they
learned to co-replicate and then that
was sort of the way you jump started
life so those are usually considered to
be protocell models
i don't know how frequently they occur
my understanding is you just have some
fatty acids they just self-assemble this
way so then the question becomes how do
you synthesize enough fatty acids to be
able to do this um
and uh and i'm i'm by no means a
membrane expert
or knowing those things um so i would
not be the person to ask about sort of
the details of the chemistry on that but
i always find those things deeply
intriguing too well sarah is there
anything that we haven't covered today
that you'd be interested in touching on
in this uh we've had a nice over two
hour and a half conversation but is
there anything else that i forgot or
didn't neglected to ask today i i don't
think so
what's next for you do you have any big
talks coming any any thoughts about book
anything uh fun for my audience writing
a book
a popular book or a text yeah yeah it's
a popular book and it's on it's on life
and what life is um
yeah that's an exclusive into the
impossible exclusive yeah yeah i haven't
talked about it much because i'm like
it's mostly written but i still believe
it to you and also it's it's hard to
write a book about a theory that's work
in progress so there's a lot of like
what is it i'm not perfect don't ask the
strength here is that they would
disagree with that yeah i know right but
but i i think part of the thing
that i'm interested in is
um
is how hard it is to work at the
frontier and and the fact that we're not
doing that alone right you you can't
especially nowadays you can't really
work on the frontier of knowledge
without
interacting with other people and i
think the alien conversation is
particularly interesting because it's
one
that i
since all of us are the phenomena of
life all of us should be able to engage
in in this problem right like all of us
have an intimate connection to the
physics we're trying to understand and
everyone has a clue it's just like how
do we stitch all those clues together to
figure out what we are right
right
exactly well sarah this has been uh so
much fun i can't wait for that book to
come out you'll have to come back on the
show when it is out
this has been a just a fascinating
conversation
uh with a deep thinker and i'm so glad
that you share your ideas with with not
only with me but with the universe the
multiverse of minds that you've
connected to
and especially with me and my audience
today thank you sarah so much yeah
thanks thanks for having me
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
so
[Music]
you